Prof: As you know,
one of the long-term themes in
our course has been intellectual
history,
and the impact of epidemic
diseases on that.
And this morning,
in that light,
I'm going to be looking at one
of the great medical debates--
in particular,
a great medical debate of the
nineteenth century--
which was the so-called debate
between contagionism and
anticontagionism.
Now, why would we be interested
in it?
First of all,
if we're going to understand
nineteenth-century medicine,
we have to realize that if you
were to go back,
say, to reading The
Lancet, one of the major
medical journals of the
nineteenth century,
or say the Proceedings of
the French Academy of
Medicine,
you would see that they
were--one of the leading issues
that was being hotly debated was
the rights and wrongs,
the scientific evidence for and
against,
the idea of contagionism,
and its opponents,
the idea of anticontagionism.
This was really a hot-button
topic in nineteenth century
medicine.
It consumed the middle decades
of the century.
So, if we're going to--if part
of our course is to understand
what was happening in the world
of medicine, well this debate
was really crucial in it.
Another part of our interest in
this debate is that it brings to
a conclusion much of our
consideration of Asiatic
cholera.
We've talked about the impact
of cholera, and we need to
recognize that its impact was
partly in the realm of ideas.
Its legacy didn't include just
death, fear, social tension.
It didn't just leave behind it
sewer lines and water pipes,
in Britain, the broad
boulevards of Paris and Lyon,
the rebuilt Lower City of
Naples;
in addition it left behind it a
major debate on the causes of
disease, and epidemic diseases
in particular.
And this is the debate between
contagionism and
anticontagionism.
It's useful for us to turn to
this debate also because it
helps us to prepare the ground
for one of the most important
discoveries in the history of
science,
and certainly medical science,
and that's the establishment of
the germ theory of disease,
which is our topic for next
week.
So, what we'll want to do then
is we'll be moving towards the
victory of contagionism.
This is a debate then that
really mattered in medical
history.
Now, in discussing this issue,
there are a couple of pitfalls
that I think we ought to avoid.
They're distorting and make it
difficult for us really to
understand history in general,
and history of science in
particular.
Let me point out two pitfalls.
The first is a possibility of
what's been called the Whiggish
view of history.
In its application to science,
it sees history of science as a
linear, upward march of truth,
moving steadily forward over
ignorance and obscurantism;
that is, a history of constant
progress.
And it's reinforced if our
history of science deals and
examines exclusively the ideas
that finally triumph,
so that we study only a
constant progress,
the march from one great idea
to the next.
Another possible danger and
pitfall is what's called
presentism,
which I might define as the
rather smug view that science
all along has been striving,
almost in Lamarckian manner,
to make the benighted people of
the past finally emerge as smart
as we are,
and we get to look back
condescendingly on the thinkers
of past centuries,
giving them marks for how right
or how wrong we now know that
they were.
So, to avoid those pitfalls,
what I'd like to do is to
approach this in a different
spirit.
Next time I will take the more
traditional path of looking at
the victorious germ theory of
disease,
and at that point we'll pay our
respects to the famous trio of
nineteenth-century science that
you all know of:
Louis Pasteur,
Robert Koch, Joseph Lister.
And in doing that,
we'll notice that what
triumphed wasn't only
disembodied scientific truth--
I'm not disputing,
let me stress this,
I'm not going to be disputing
the truth of the germ theory of
disease.
But what I'll want to do is
something a little more subtle,
which is to notice that what
triumphed wasn't just
disembodied truth,
but also a worldview,
and that when that worldview
won out,
there were some losses as well,
that went with it.
The germ theory of disease is
one of the greatest advances in
the history of science.
But we need to argue that
although true,
it perhaps wasn't the entirely
of truth,
and that its establishment as a
reigning orthodoxy,
by the end of the nineteenth
century--
because it does,
in fact, come to be held by the
entirety of the international
medical community really after
around the 1890s or so.
And that brought with it one of
its consequences--
an unintended one--was certain
negative impacts on
understanding of disease that
we'll be talking about.
And to understand and
appreciate this fact,
I'm going to concentrate this
morning not on the victors--
you know about them already,
to some extent,
and we'll be turning to them
for the whole of next week--
but I'd like to look instead at
someone you probably don't know,
or maybe not know at all.
In fact, just out of curiously,
before we talked about him in
our course and reading,
how many of you had actually
heard of Max van Pettenkofer?
See, that's what I suspected,
actually no one had heard of
Max van Pettenkofer.
All the more reason we're going
to--the good news for you is
we're going to be dealing with
him for the next forty minutes
or so.
He's the most sophisticated and
scientifically robust of those
who were, as we might call,
wrong.
He lived from 1818 to 1901,
and one of the great figures of
nineteenth century medical
science,
although his scientific defeat
was total and humiliating by the
1890s.
And, indeed,
that might form part of the
background to the fact that he
was to commit suicide at the
turn of the twentieth century,
when he shot himself.
But I'm going to try to
understand that he was not just
simply wrong,
but I'll argue that he was
splendidly wrong;
that his mistaken ideas
actually saved millions of
lives,
and that their defeat had a
paradoxical consequence,
not only of advancing medical
science,
but in some ways impoverishing
it, in ways that are important
and that we might want to
consider.
Well, who was Max van
Pettenkofer?
And since you hadn't met him
before, let me introduce you to
him.
And here he is, in splendor.
And he was a German scientist
and physician.
In particular--map of
Germany--Pettenkofer is
associated with Bavaria,
here in the south of
Germany--let's look at that a
little more closely--
and he was associated
especially with the city of
Munich.
And I'm pointing this out to
you, not simply so that you'll
know where he's from;
although that's nice to know.
But this is extremely
significant in his theories,
in that he tends to be the
defender of localism and the
autonomy of Bavaria and Munich,
against the centralizing
tendencies of Germany as a
whole.
So, it has a political
significance that we'll be
turning to.
Now, what were his social
origins?
Who was he?
He came from a Catholic family
of very modest means but lots of
children.
And the family,
that is his nuclear family,
didn't really have the means to
afford him with a higher
education,
and he gained that because of
an uncle.
He had a wealthier uncle,
who was a prominent apothecary,
but alas, had no sons,
and he wanted his nephew,
Max, to carry on the family
business.
So, Max van Pettenkofer started
out life by studying pharmacy
and chemistry,
and this, in fact,
was to have an impact on his
medical theories.
But he soon discovered that he
hated the subjects he had
originally enrolled in to study,
and he terminally disappointed
his uncle when he enrolled as a
medical student.
And he gained his medical
degree in 1843 from the
University of Munich.
Thereafter, he had a varied
career for a few years,
casting about for what he
wanted to do in life.
He worked for a while for a
mint, and he even had a failed
attempt to become a stage actor.
But in 1847,
he gained appointment to the
medical faculty at Munich,
and became also a professor of
organic chemistry.
From then on,
he enjoyed a meteoric career as
one of the rising stars of
science in Bavaria and Germany,
and Europe in general.
He became advisor to the
Bavarian Government,
and a full Professor of
Medicine in 1853.
Now, 1854 changed his life,
and it did so in relationship
to an outbreak of Asiatic
cholera in Germany.
And it's interesting that this
is the very same epidemic that
Snow studied in London.
But whereas Snow was a
contagionist,
Pettenkofer reached the exact
opposite conclusion;
indeed, thereafter he became a
lifelong opponent of Snow's
ideas and what he referred to,
with scorn, as "the
English water mania."
The English,
he said, were obsessed with
water.
Well, what was the debate and
why was it so passionately held?
Now, the debate was obviously
about the issue of whether
diseases are contagious or not.
But it didn't involve all
disease.
No one doubted,
in the nineteenth century,
that syphilis,
for example,
was contagious.
The debate was about a subset
of diseases,
five in particular:
leprosy, typhus,
and then what we might call
"the big three":
plague,
yellow fever and cholera.
In other words,
the debate centered on the
diseases that were the most
feared diseases of the
nineteenth century,
and so the debate was
passionate because it concerned
diseases that were extremely
important.
And it wasn't just a matter of
academic disagreement.
The decision on whether you
defined a disease as contagious
or not had a practical
importance.
It meant what are going to be
the public health strategies
that you'd devise to combat it?
And the European powers were
greatly divided as to whether
they should defend themselves by
quarantine, the great
contagionist measure,
or not.
Well the two sides in the
debate then were contagionism
and anticontagionism.
Let's start with contagionism.
This wasn't a new idea at all
in the nineteenth century.
But it was unknown to the
Greeks.
But it was part of biblical
tradition.
And you've heard of its
popularization already by the
Italian physician Fracastoro in
the sixteenth century.
Contagionism had a widespread
importance in popular culture as
well.
The contagionist idea,
by the nineteenth century,
was that there was some
infectious material.
Some people thought it was a
poison--a chemical,
in other words.
Others, that it might be--it
was pure speculation--
a living entity,
an animalcule--you'll see that
word in John Snow,
for example,
in one of his speculative
moments--
that was transmitted in some
manner,
perhaps person to person,
perhaps through the pores,
perhaps by contact with a sick
person,
perhaps by objects that had
been in contact with that
person.
And you've just been reading a
very powerful expression of the
contagionist position,
and that's the work of John
Snow.
But an important thing to
remember was that down to the
1890s,
contagionism--and this may
surprise you--
was primarily the standpoint of
popular culture,
rather than of the medical
elite.
Whereas anticontagionism
dominated the international
medical profession.
Most men of science regarded
contagionism as a view held by
the ignorant and the
superstitious,
and indeed the irony is that
contagionism reached a nadir,
in respectability,
just before the work of Koch
and Pasteur demonstrated its
ultimate vitality.
To understand that,
take an example that by now you
know extremely well,
and that is plague.
To the layman,
the spread of plague seemed to
justify the idea that by some
means,
that people still didn't
understand,
it spread from one person to
another.
But to the learned physician,
the case for contagion still
seemed weak.
There wasn't a mechanism to
explain what it was,
how it was transmitted.
In many cases,
close inspection seemed to
demonstrate that the disease
spread without the direct
contact that the contagionist
view seemed to postulate.
People caught the plague who
hadn't been in immediate contact
with another plague victim.
Conversely, where there was
such contact,
often the plague didn't spread,
and people who cared for a
plague victim sometimes didn't
fall ill.
How could that be explained?
Furthermore,
epidemics of plague began and
ended in the most mysterious
manner, that no one could
plausibly explain.
And to strengthen their case,
the contagionists would need to
discard their theory of
inanimate contagion,
replacing it with something
that was living.
Furthermore,
there was the need for the idea
of transmission of over
distance, by water perhaps,
food supplies,
or later, we'll see,
insect vectors.
But the debate was also fueled
by political conclusions,
by politics,
because major conclusions
followed from the position that
one adopted.
Contagionists,
in their scientific
conclusions, were people who
buttressed the power of the
state.
Because in the name of state
power, one could institute the
most draconian measures:
cordons, lazarettos,
quarantine.
You could sequester and confine
individuals, you could limit
civil liberty,
and you could radically control
the movement of goods and of
trade.
So, one of the results then of
contagionism--you can see here
the idea.
Here you have cholera,
yellow fever and plague trying
to enter the citadel at the
gates.
And here we have quarantine and
the draconian measures that
follow from that.
Cleanliness,
you know--by now,
you're experts on the filth
theory of disease and the
measures to be adopted against
it.
The idea of contagionism
buttressed those ideas of a
strong, powerful state
interventionism.
Let's turn then to their
opponents, the
anticontagionists,
the people who were skeptical
with regard to the ideas of John
Snow.
These were largely associated
with the political left.
Why?
Anticontagionism implied free
trade.
It was associated with
liberalism, and with the defense
of individual liberties against
arbitrary state bureaucracies.
It implied opposition to
extreme, and sometimes violent,
plague measures of public
health.
So, it wasn't by coincidence
that it was a good idea to look
at a map of Germany,
because the most important of
the contagionists,
Robert Koch,
was an icon and promoter of the
power of the centralized German
state.
He worked in Berlin,
and that wasn't by chance,
and he defended the
centralizing and imperial
interests of the German Reich.
Whereas Pettenkofer was a
liberal,
who championed the local
interests of Bavaria and Munich,
and indeed his theories
coincided--both medically and
politically,
they were sometimes referred to
as localism.
Another way of seeing the
stakes in this debate is to
remember that Britain long
opposed the contagionist
position,
in part for political and
economic reasons.
That is to say,
Britain was ranged in the
international conferences
largely with anticontagionists;
in part because its interests
prospered best through free
trade,
and it felt threatened by
medical arguments that implied
that the state should interfere
with commerce,
impounding British ships and
quarantining their crews for
forty days.
The anticontagionists also had
the imprimatur,
should we like,
of tradition,
of the authority of tradition.
Their views were sanctioned by
Hippocrates and Galen,
and were buttressed by a whole
panoply of ideas that had grown
up later but were,
if we like, compatible with the
traditional practice of
medicine,
with the idea of atmospheric
influences,
of the epidemic constitution,
as it was called--
a bit of jargon for you--of the
atmosphere.
And it was compatible with the
filth and miasmic theory.
Let's also remember that
anticontagionism inspired some
robust health measures as well,
and it saved lives.
Anticontagionism was the view
of people like Chadwick,
whom you know now,
and his associate,
Southwood Smith.
It was the view of Haussmann
and the Second Empire,
and it was the official
doctrine of risanamento;
that is, the rebuilding of
Naples.
Now, in the history of medicine
and public health,
and epidemiology,
the cholera epidemic of 1854
looms large,
giving rise to two foundational
texts of epidemiology,
on opposite sides of the debate.
On the one side we see John
Snow;
and you've read his On the
Mode of Communication of
Cholera,
the final version of which--it
was first drafted in 1849,
but the draft that you have
appeared after this event.
And this was the classic
statement of the contagionist
view,
to the extent that it could be
supported without the definitive
evidence later provided by
microscopy.
So, Snow did everything that it
was possible to do,
purely on the basis of
epidemiological evidence.
There was going to need to be a
conceptual shift in order to
clinch his view and demonstrate
it so that it was broadly
accepted.
On the other side,
we see a book that's been--it's
not even on our own reading
list--a book that's been largely
forgotten.
This is Max van Pettenkofer's
work called Investigations
and Observations on the Method
of Spread of Cholera,
published in 1855.
And this--I should say that
Pettenkofer was no less rigorous
as an epidemiologist than John
Snow.
And this was a major
foundational text in
epidemiology.
It was a study of the 1854
epidemic in Bavaria,
reaching conclusions that were
diametrically opposed to those
of Snow.
From 1854, cholera became a
lifelong preoccupation of Max
van Pettenkofer,
and he devoted himself to the
epidemiological study of the
disease,
staking his reputation on high
profile debates with Robert
Koch.
He was to write some two
hundred articles and books
during his lifetime,
on a whole range of scientific
topics.
But the largest number,
about sixty,
were devoted to cholera,
and its transmission and cause.
So, Pettenkofer--and the reason
we're dealing with him now is he
was the last major,
and the best,
defender of the
anticontagionist doctrine,
of miasmatism, in other words.
And he defended it until his
death at the dawn of the
twentieth century.
He adopted the traditional
doctrine, dating back to
antiquity, but provided it with
a new evidence-based,
scientific underpinning.
Well, why was Pettenkofer not
convinced by Snow when it came
to cholera?
Part of the reason you know.
Contagionism,
Pettenkofer said--and in this
he was right--it didn't produce
a really plausible mechanism for
the transmission of the disease.
It correlated cholera cases
with drinking water.
But to Pettenkofer,
there seemed no means of
explaining exactly what was
transmitted, or how.
Also, as you know,
Pettenkofer had been trained as
a chemist,
and he looked at the
traditional idea that the
cholera poison was some sort of
chemical substance,
and he argued that it was
entirely improbable that a
disease could be spread then in
the manner postulated.
Looking at London and the River
Thames, how could a poison
contaminating the Thames,
if it was a chemical,
not be infinitely diluted?
Furthermore,
he said there was a whole
series of what we might call
cholera mysteries that Snow's
position didn't help to
illuminate.
Why did an epidemic start,
and why did it end?
Why could doctors provide their
services in the midst of an
epidemic of cholera and yet not
fall ill of it themselves?
What caused the pronounced
seasonality of cholera?
Why was its onset almost
invariably in the spring and the
summer?
And why did an outbreak always
seem to ebb with the onset of
cold weather?
And then lastly,
for the moment,
there was what we might call
the problem of Lyon;
that is, the great second city
of France.
If cholera is contagious,
and if it follows the great
routes of trade and population
movement,
why is it that there are,
nonetheless,
major centers that escaped
throughout the nineteenth
century?
Lyon was the second largest
city in France,
located at the hub of a network
of trade and transportation,
and it had all the--it was a
great textile center of
manufacturing--
and it had all the urban
problems of an industrial center
at its time.
If ever, Pettenkofer would say,
there was a city that seemed
primed to be devastated by
Asiatic cholera,
it was Lyon,
and yet it escaped the
visitations of this exotic
Asiatic outsider.
Well, what was Pettenkofer's
theory?
And it was his delight to
believe that he could provide an
apparently clear,
epidemiologically-based
explanation for all of those
cholera mysteries.
Indeed, another aspect of his
theory--that Robert Koch
discovered the Vibrio
cholerae.
You've seen a picture of the
Vibrio.
And he discovered it in 1883.
Pettenkofer didn't reject the
idea of the Vibrio.
Instead, he incorporated it
elegantly into his larger
theory,
explaining that it played a
role in the etiology of cholera,
but that its role and its
mechanism were completely
different from the ones that
Koch espoused.
Pettenkofer's theory is often
referred to as the groundwater
theory.
We've seen it can be called
localism.
It can be called the
groundwater theory.
The simplest approach to his
method is a very simple
mathematical equation,
that he was very fond of
himself, for illustrative
purposes.
It was perhaps the simplest of
all mathematical formulas:
X Y = Z.
What did that mean to Max van
Pettenkofer?
Well, for him,
Z was a cholera outbreak,
the result then of combining X
and Y.
It's produced,
in other words,
under certain specific
conditions of two other factors,
the X factor and the Y factor.
The X factor,
he said, was the presence of
the Vibrio cholerae.
You see, he accepts that the
Vibrio plays a role.
But for Pettenkofer,
the Vibrio itself,
on its own, would never make
you sick.
You could swallow it quite
safely and remain entirely
healthy.
He regarded it as harmless on
its own,
and as we'll see in a moment,
he carried out a famous
auto-experiment in which he
tried to demonstrate
conclusively the truth of his
view.
In other words,
he made himself a cocktail of
the Vibrio cholerae and
drank it,
and, in fact,
he remained healthy,
and therefore persuaded,
to the end of his life,
that the Vibrio on its
own was harmless.
He was to say that the
Vibrio causes disease in
an entirely different,
but orthodox,
miasmatic manner.
The danger doesn't arise when
the Vibrio contaminates
food and drinking water.
The problem is different.
It happens when the
Vibrio gets into the soil
beneath a major city.
And there, Pettenkofer used a
horticultural analogy,
referring to germination or
fermentation.
After the Vibrio gained
access to the soil,
under certain conditions it
could germinate like a plant and
give off its poison into the air
above,
that the population inhaled,
and those who were susceptible
fell ill in large numbers,
and it was then that you'd have
the onset of an epidemic.
In nineteenth-century medical
parlance,
cholera was an example of a
whole category of diseases that
were called zymotic diseases,
diseases caused by fermentation.
So that we see the X factor
involves the Vibrio
cholerae.
Then the Y factor was simply
those local conditions--
again localism--that were
necessary for fermentation to
take place,
and for poison to be given off
into the atmosphere.
What makes up the Y factor?
Again let's think of
horticulture and the growth of a
plant.
A plant doesn't need only soil
to develop, it also needs
nutrients and fertilizer.
And here was the critical role
of filth and excrement.
They were, in Pettenkofer's
mind, the nutrients for this
plant, the Vibrio
cholerae.
Unsanitary urban conditions
literally fed the Vibrio.
Sewage was dangerous,
not because it got into the
water,
but because it seeped into the
soil beneath the city,
nourishing the Vibrio
and giving rise to fermentation.
But there's more to it,
in Pettenkofer's epidemiology.
Like a plant,
fermentation required a number
of other preconditions.
It needed water;
plants always need water.
It needed a warm temperature.
It needed air and porous soil
in which to grow.
And it was at this point that
we see why Pettenkofer's theory
is sometimes called the
groundwater theory.
Groundwater was important to
his analysis because he
considered variations in the
water table beneath the city to
be a measure of the capacity of
a soil beneath the city to
support fermentation and give
rise to cholera epidemics.
Too high a water table would be
like flooding,
and that would kill the plant.
Too low a table would be like a
drought or a desert.
So, for a cholera epidemic,
the ideal was an ebbing water
table that left moist,
porous soil above it;
a condition that was likely to
be characteristic of the early
summer.
And indeed, Pettenkofer now
thought he understood the
seasonality of cholera.
He could explain its
seasonality by reference to the
water table of European and
other cities.
Armed with this theory,
Pettenkofer proceeded to
conduct exhaustive
epidemiological studies of the
local conditions of localities
vulnerable to cholera.
For Pettenkofer,
it seemed obvious why
mountainous areas--the Alps,
for example--weren't afflicted
with cholera.
There, there was such a deep
layer of insulation between the
groundwater and the population,
who were therefore protected
from the cholera poison.
Similarly, desert areas
provided no conditions for
fermentation.
Pettenkofer also thought that
he had solved the Lyon problem.
By investigating and studying
Lyon, he realized that it was
built on a thick layer of
impenetrable granite.
It was built on stone,
and therefore provided no
opportunity for fermentation and
germination.
The best conditions were
provided by cities that were
built at sea level,
on alluvial,
porous soil.
This could explain why Naples
was ravaged, Paris,
London, Calcutta.
And then he decided,
being an honest scientist,
that he should also
investigate, in particular,
the hard case,
the one that seemed to conflict
with his theories,
and that was the Island of
Malta.
Malta was built on rock,
but it experienced disaster
during recurring cholera
pandemics,
and he thought,
to his own satisfaction,
that he could solve the riddle.
Malta, unlike Lyon,
was not built on impermeable
granite.
It had everything to do with
the specifics of the stone
itself.
Malta was built on porous,
soft limestone,
and that provided infinite
air-filled cavities,
that if watered and fertilized,
in warm conditions,
would provide wonderful places
for germination.
You can see Pettenkofer
visiting Malta,
which he did,
and having his eureka moment.
He did core samples.
I'm trying to say that
Pettenkofer was a very
conscientious research
scientist, and a strong
epidemiologist.
And he went further.
He argued also that he could
explain not only which cities
were most afflicted by cholera,
but also the very neighborhoods
within them.
Low-lying areas,
close to the water table,
would be vulnerable to cholera.
Neighborhoods built on hills
would be protected.
Naples was a good example.
The Lower City was ravaged,
the Upper City was not,
and Pettenkofer thought he knew
why.
Neapolitans,
as you know,
in fact agreed with him,
and Pettenkofer's theories were
much admired there.
It seemed to explain Neapolitan
history, and it was his theories
that were the very basis for the
rebuilding project.
He saw his great achievement as
that of developing a single
unified theory,
with no internal
contradictions,
that could explain all the
known facts of cholera,
and clarify those puzzling
cholera mysteries.
Now, an interesting point about
Pettenkofer's theories.
They're now rejected by modern
science.
But during the nineteenth
century, they provided a major
impetus to undertake needed
sanitary reform.
His ideas therefore can be
credited probably with saving
hundreds of thousands of lives,
from a variety of diarrheal
illnesses;
cholera, of course,
but also typhoid,
gastroenteritis.
So, this is a case of an idea
that we now know not to be
robust scientifically,
that nevertheless produced very
practical results that had a
major impact on combating
epidemic diseases.
Pettenkofer was responsible,
in fact, for bringing the
sanitary idea to Bavaria.
He wanted to install sewer
systems to take away waste and
fecal matter,
but not for the reason that
Snow would have.
He wasn't worried that
Bavarians would drink infected
water, or eat contaminated food.
He was afraid that the fecal
matter would get beneath the
city and would nourish the
Vibrio,
and thereby give rise to
poisonous fumes that would
poison the people.
His idea was to make the soil
of Germany's cities infertile,
and you could do that by
depriving the soil of organic
matter and excrement.
So, he wanted to supply Germany
with clean water.
But not specifically clean
drinking water,
but he wanted to prevent sewage
from gaining access to the
groundwater and the soil beneath
the city.
He also championed the idea of
sand filtration of water,
to ensure clean water.
He thought that Snow had been
seriously misled.
There was a matter of
proportion here.
Snow, he said,
was really concentrated on the
few liters that a person
consumed.
That water, he argued,
no matter how contaminated,
would actually do no harm.
The real issue was the massive
quantity of water,
of domestic,
industrial or household waste,
that carried fertilizer to the
city soil,
and there dread disease.
Now, Pettenkofer recognized
then that clean water and
effective sewage,
and waste disposal,
were essential public health
measures.
So, he had--as his legacy,
Pettenkofer was the founder of
the sanitary movement in
Germany.
He was also a professor of
hygiene at the University of
Munich.
He founded a journal called
The Archive for Hygiene,
in 1883;
and indeed it's still published
as The International Journal
of Hygiene and Environmental
Health.
He was the founder of the Max
van Pettenkofer Institute in
Munich, a world-famous research
institute, dedicated to the
promotion of public health.
He became its director,
and trained people.
It became a center of research
and training,
unique at its time.
He was an important figure in
the founding of the Johns
Hopkins School of Public Health.
And along with his opponent,
John Snow, he was a founding
father in the field of
epidemiology.
His arguments,
though now largely discredited,
were supported by prodigious
fieldwork.
You can imagine him going
around Europe,
taking core samples of soil and
rock,
and correlating that with
measurements of the rise and
fall of groundwater levels,
and correlating all of that
information with rainfall,
temperature measurements,
and the history of cholera
outbreaks.
And Pettenkofer was tireless in
propagating his ideas as a
lecturer, as a writer.
He was an advisor to the
Bavarian government,
and he became president of the
Bavarian Academy of Science.
Another factor was that
Pettenkofer was quite interested
in something else as well:
what made people susceptible?
And he believed that poor
nutrition was an important
factor in that.
So, his public health policies
also involved attention to diet
and nutrition.
Of course, some of his
recommendations were misguided.
But one measure he gave great
attention to was also the siting
of infectious disease hospitals
and cemeteries.
A cholera hospital,
or a cemetery,
should be located on a hilltop,
far from the city center and
downwind of it.
That would prevent the cholera
germ from percolating down
easily into the soil beneath the
city,
and would ensure that any
poisonous miasma that arose
would be dispersed from the
population.
We can see that he helped the
way--condition--
-the way Naples,
for example,
was rebuilt,
and where the infectious
diseases hospital in that city
was located;
which was high above the city
and downwind from it.
And as I said,
to prove his theory,
he tried his dangerous
auto-experiment.
His theory was losing ground by
1892,
when there was a major epidemic
of cholera at Hamburg,
in Germany, and Pettenkofer and
Robert Koch were greatly at
odds.
To prove his case,
Pettenkofer challenged Koch to
provide him with a cholera
cocktail, that he volunteered to
swallow.
Koch's collaborator,
Gaffke, duly dispatched a vial
filled with Vibrio.
There's some interesting ethical
issues here,
as Gaffke sent Pettenkofer what
he thought was a fatal dose of
cholera,
and fully expected Pettenkofer
to die an agonizing death.
There are then various accounts
of what happened next.
One account has it that
Pettenkofer's lab assistants
intercepted the package and
diluted the dose.
It's also true that the cholera
cocktail was sent in February,
and it may well be that the
cold temperature in transit
attenuated the virulence of the
Vibrio. In any case,
Pettenkofer was a man convinced
of his theory.
He put his life on the line to
prove it, and he duly swallowed
the vial that Koch's lab had
provided.
He fell seriously ill of
diarrhea, but didn't develop the
symptoms he recognized as
Asiatic cholera.
He rapidly recovered,
and was convinced that he'd
proved that the Vibrio
cholerae does not directly
cause the disease,
not by being ingested.
Well, there was an unhappy
sequel for Pettenkofer.
Koch's microbiology,
by the 1890s,
convinced the medical world of
the germ theory,
and miasmatic doctrine of all
kinds,
including Pettenkoffer's own,
were discredited.
In 1894, he resigned his
university chair.
In 1899, he resigned from his
other offices.
In the 1890s also,
three of his five children
died, and his wife.
And on February 9^(th),
1901, Pettenkofer committed
suicide.
Well, there's a final aspect
I'd like to raise in my last
minute,
and that is to say the defeat
of anti-contagionism may have
had some negative legacies,
that it took time to recognize.
One of the strengths of
Pettenkofer's ideas was the
stress they put on what we would
now call the environmental,
social and economic
determinants of disease.
For a time, the germ theory of
disease relegated those aspects
of medicine to the background,
leading to a narrow-gauge
stress on microbes,
and the attempt to find magic
bullets to destroy them.
So, Pettenkofer then was
ultimately wrong.
But I would argue that his
ideas were magnificently wrong,
and that they contained
important elements of truth,
and important and vital
measures for public health and
for medicine.
Next time, we'll take the high
road and move on to the victors
in this debate--
Pasteur, Koch,
Lister--and the successful
proof of the truth of
contagionism and the germ theory
of disease.
But I thought you needed a
moment with Max von.